Jetzt gibt es etwas zu gewinnen und die chancen stehen extrem gut weil ich bin ein wenig stolz die dritte auflage
des youtube hoch ist raus und ihr könnt es gewinnen und in diesem video die erfolgsfaktoren für
Youtube erfahren es ist nämlich ganz leicht
eigentlich und ich kann nur aus eigener erfahrung sagen wenn ihr diese regeln beachtet ist der erfolg nahezu unausweichlich
Also, los geht es mit den top-10 erfolgsfaktoren für den youtube erfolg wahl klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja immer wenn ich einen vortrag über den erfolg auf youtube halten dann sind es zehn
Erfolgsfaktoren die wirklich auf youtube zählen und ich selbst setze sie bei den united creatures um wo ich einige kanäle für funk das junge angebot
von ard und zdf betreue zum beispiel lido fast ein jahr lang haben wir zusammen gearbeitet
Und dann erst gegen der kanal durch die decke noch
Im januar 2017 waren es 30.000 videoabrufe pro monat doch dann schnellten die zahlen von 60.000
Im april auf bis zu 8 millionen hoch und jetzt liegt video bei rund drei millionen views
Tendenz steigend hier also jetzt die top-10
erfolgsfaktoren für youtube die erste lektion oder wie hier bei einem top 10 video
Ist aus der 10 das
durchhaltevermögen
Ja worum geht es da viele menschen glauben die auf youtube anfang mit dem ersten video kommt direkt der riesige erfolg
Das gibt es in ganz großen ausnahmefällen aber eigentlich ist das nicht der fall, man
muss einfach durchhalten das kann wochen
monate jahre dauern es gibt zwei indizien die dafür sprechen dass man erfolg haben wird
Und das ist zum einen die watch time also die zeit die ein video geguckt wird
Und das ist die zahl der views wenn die beides steigt also wenn das wort stand gut es so ich sag mal mindestens
60 prozent besser 70 80 prozent und die views langsam nach. Oben gehen dann wird irgendwann der erfolg kommen und da gibt es den berühmten
umgedrehten hockey stick der geht nämlich so
Und dann irgendwann kommt der erfolg aber man sieht am anfang ist das total langsam es muss nur nach oben gehen die zahl der würfe
Dann wird der erfolg kommen und die nächste lektion ist wie
reichweite
Dann geht es darum zu gucken wie komme ich an mehr views an mehr abonnenten das heißt wie kann ich meine reichweite
steigern das geht natürlich selbst dadurch dass man viel twittert 4 kommentare
Beantwortet mit anderen youtube an kommuniziert unter videos kommentiert und so weiter und so fort
Und eben auch cola boss macht das heißt immer gucken wer es ungefähr gleich groß oder ein bisschen größer wer hat lust
Mit mir kulabas zu machen und übrigens ein ganz wichtiges kriterium
umso besser die eigenen videos sind umso eher
harmlose lust mit einem kollaps zu machen die viel viel mehr abonnenten und views haben also
Qualität ist ein entscheidendes kriterium aber das kommt noch viel später hier in unserer liste und auf der acht die
Personelle die
Persönlichkeit auf deutsch aber wir sprechen ein wenig denglisch seit
eine person eine persönlichkeit ein charakter zeigt wer ihr seid ich bin davon überzeugt
Dass der youtube algorithmus sehr genau darauf guckt ob man wirklich leute binden kann
Denn nur wenn man leute binden kann bleiben sie auch dabei und abonnenten und fans und eine community die
Gewinnt, man durch eine personelle die eine persönlichkeit in jemand da ist die darf nicht
Im vordergrund stehen aber sie ist entscheidend und wichtig und ich kann nur dazu auffordern
Nicht irgendwer zu sein sondern mal selbst und seinen eigenen charakter dazu
Zu nutzen um eben eine persönlichkeit auf dem kanal zu sein auf der 7 die
Community
Ja das machen vor allen dingen professionelle produzenten gerne falsch die denken. Hey, ich mache ein
Gigantisch tolles video dann lade ich das auf youtube hoch und dann wird es ein erfolg
Pustekuchen das wissen alle die ein bisschen erfahrung mit youtube haben das reicht einfach nicht so ein entscheidender punkt ist
Youtube ist mit facebook eine der größten
social media webseiten denn youtube ist nicht nur videos sondern youtube ist eben auch eine social media community
Und die kann man nutzen um seine eigene community aufzubauen likes discs kommentare
Abonnements das alles sind ganz wichtige punkte die man ja nicht außer acht lassen darf, man
Muss gucken dass man abonnenten gewinnt auch wenn sie nachher für den algorithmus nicht so wichtig sind aber die bauen die
community auf dann auf kommentare
Reagieren zu gucken wer setzt discs wehr setzt likes wann
Passiert was mit welchem video erreiche ich wählen und so weiter und so fort also ganz wichtig kümmert euch
Um eure community auch auf twitter auch auf facebook guckt was am besten funktioniert ganz wichtig
reichweiten kann man nicht viel schieben aber man kann die leute ja zur richtigen fans machen und zu einer
community auf der sechs die
Leidenschaft das hat nicht nur etwas mit
Einer liebesbeziehung zu tun sondern auch mit dem was man tut leidenschaft ist wahnsinnig wichtig das was man
macht deswegen mache ich
Wissenschafts videos weil das ist meine leidenschaft das ist etwas wo ich quasi mein hobby zum beruf gemacht hat das interessiert mich wirklich
ich lese täglich ich weiß nicht dutzende artikel über irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse und
darüber dann beiträge zu machen und auch mal vielleicht das eine oder andere zu entdecken
Informationen zu verbinden was andere vielleicht nicht so machen und das täglich das ist meine leidenschaft
Und ich kann jedem nur raten macht nichts wofür keine leidenschaft
Habt nichts was ich eigentlich nicht
Interessiert oder ja wo ihr einfach was euch kalt lässt macht etwas was euch ja wirklich
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes heiß macht wo er heiß drauf seid und eben wo er leidenschaft
Empfindet nur dann könnt ihr auch den zuschauer die zuschauerin auf der anderen seite
Erreichen wenn ihr für das was er da vor der kamera macht brennt das ist extrem wichtig also leidenschaft
Seit leidenschaftlich auf der 5 auch extrem wir jetzt wird es immer wichtiger und entscheidender
Und auf der fünf ist
Programm
Lasst eure zuschauer zuschauerin spüren dass sie ein programm
Habt dass ihr regelmäßig videos macht dass sie erwarten können dass wenn sie euch treu bleiben dass, er sie auch regelmäßig mit
videos versorgt denn wenn sie das merken dann kommen sie immer wieder wieder und das ist ein ganz entscheidender punkt beim fernsehen haben wir ja
Dass das bestimmte sendungen immer zu einer bestimmten zeit kommen und genau so funktioniert es auch auf
Youtube wenn er an einem ganz bestimmten tag zu einer ganz bestimmten uhrzeit eurer
video online stellt das merkt die community das merke eure fans eure zuschauer euro abonnenten
Und die kommen auch von sich aus dann wieder und gucken
Selbst haye kommt da das neue aktuelle video das ist ganz entscheidend für den algorithmus
Denn sagt dann sagte ihm hey ich habe eine community die sich wirklich für das interessiert was ich mache und
Mit programm mit etwas was ja regelmäßig kommt da hilft dir ganz deutlich
eurem euren zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
zu merken hey hier
Komme ich immer wieder hin um die und die zeit an dem in den tag
oder ich vielleicht auch täglich wenn er das schafft ist es noch besser für den algorithmus und
Ich möchte unbedingt die videos sehen die dann, um diese zeit kommen also programm ganz entscheidend was viele vergessen auf der vier die
online video
optimierung weil online video ist anders als fernsehen das vergessen viele
Ich muss ein video anders strukturieren das fängt ja schon damit an dass ich am ende
Am besten eine end karte ab wo ich zum abonnieren auffordere und zum gucken weiterer videos dass das video am anfang ganz
bestimmt strukturiertes
Dh den ersten 15 sekunden erzähle
Ich warum das das geilste was es überhaupt auf youtube gibt danach kommt ein
Grafisches intro und dann geht es langsam los und am besten mit einer ganz tollen dramaturgie wo man etwas ankündigt
am besten auch schon
Im intro was dann erst am ende aufgelöst wird wie bei dem tollen krimi bei einfach einem tollen buch oder einem tollen spielfilm die
Auflösung kommt erst am schluss das ist ganz wichtig da natürlich titel
samt mail video beschreibung all diese dinge dass man sich wirklich
Auf online video konzentriert und sich darauf konzentriert was dort anders ist wenn man da nur business as usual macht also
Geschäft wie üblich wie fernsehproduktionen das oft machen dann wird man einfach überhaupt keinen erfolg haben wir nähern uns langsam dem ende
ganz wichtig und wird manchmal vergessen
Professionalität
Und dazu, gehört was er gerade hatten die online video optimierung es gibt eben
professionelle
videoproduktionen zum beispiel die das vergessen und das ist unprofessionell aber jedem anderen muss ich auch sagen guter ton gutes licht
gutes bild scharf deutlich und so weiter und so fort
Das ist professionell vergesst es nie
Manchmal sehe ich dann eben introns, am anfang von online-videos und das in einer ganzen
Reihe oder immer ähnliches vom nails oder oder oder das ist unprofessionell
Seid nicht so seit professionell vergesst nicht
Im ganzen trott das alles wichtig ist das kann man und das ist auch leicht aber tut es nicht dann
werdet ihr viel schneller zum erfolg kommen und jetzt ein ganz wichtiger fachbegriff auf der 2 er heißt
krass
seit krass macht etwas was
Niemand erwartet das kann ein ganz fantastisches thema sein das kann ein tolles skript sein das kann ein aufwändiger dreh sein das kann
irgendetwas sein was niemand erwartet
verblüfft die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer und macht dinge die dann auch weiter geteilt werden weil das ist das entscheidende bei
Kras wer im fernsehen es ist genau das gleiche die größten erfolge. Hatten krasse formate ich sag nur stefan raab mit der wok
wm und der stock car crash
challenge und
Schlag den raab und so weiter und so fort das war alles krass die leute haben darüber geredet
Am nächsten tag und wenn er krasser seit und ich sag mal zumindest einmal. Im monat ein
leuchtturm video also ein herausragendes video macht dann wird über euch geredet dann werdet ihr verbreitet und auch, so
werdet ihr schneller zum erfolg kommen das heißt krasse videos
Absolut wichtig ja und auf der einst total abgedroschen manche werden sich jetzt der hohen zu halten
Ich sag's trotzdem
Content ist king und das ist wirklich entscheiden und nicht irgendwelche content weil viele länder so hin und denkt
Na ja irgendwas ist ja klar konnte den content content eben nicht irgendwas viele brand channels also
werbekanäle vor unternehmen machen das zum beispiel falsch die
Machen ständig werbung werbung ist kein content trailer für filme und games ja aber für alles andere was
Werblich ist das will kein mensch gucken es muss content seien immer mehr werbetreibende begreifen dass auch aber
Viele macher haben es noch nicht begriffen die machen irgendetwas und wichtig ist dass es
Wirkliche content ist also etwas was den zuschauer weiter bringt besonders gut unterhält besonders gut informiert
verblüffen toll umgesetzt ist aufschlussreich ist
Und so weiter und so fort also macht wirklichen content irgendwas
Zu machen reicht einfach nicht es muss besonders gut seien besonders herausragend darauf solltet ihr konzert
konzentrieren das kann natürlich nicht immer der fall sein ich mache täglich videos und ich kann sagen nicht jedes video ist herausragend ganz klar aber
Ich bemühe mich mit leidenschaft mit professionalität und jetzt kommen noch, mal alle top tens nein ich lasse es aber
das ist wirklich
Entscheidend bleibt dran macht guten content und dann wird erfolg kommen und sich weiterbilden informieren soll ja auch helfen
Ich hab da einen kleinen tipp dann ist es wirklich das steht so ziemlich alles drin was man wissen muss ich kann es nur empfehlen
Ganz klar ich bin auch ein wenig voreingenommen aber wirklich fragt leute die es vielleicht schon haben es ist echt ein ziemlich umfangreiches
gutes und ausführliches und nahezu komplettes
Nachschlagwerk und man hat es glaube ich ganz flott durch gelesen also viel spaß dabei und jetzt kommt die schon mit preisen
Beantwortet mir eine frage wie hat ein video auf youtube anzufangen also, im besten fall wie ist es
am anfang strukturiert damit die watch time optimal ist schickt eure antworten an
Info at united creators dot net mit dem betreff
Youtube erfolg falls sie es nicht erwarten können der link zum buch ist in der video beschreibung genau so wie die
teilnahmebedingungen ich freue mich auf zahlreiche mails wenn ihr kein video von pixum verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die knochen nur dann
Wäre da auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter dafür drauf klicken die zukunft
Des fernsehens ist online ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran